e la tutti vuoi un ep minuti e benvenuti
a chistu nuovo video e gas ne so io ci
ho provato a fare traduzione in
napoletano apprezzato il tentativo che
lo chiedete sempre tutti non riesco a
parlare neanche una sillaba siamo
alternati su quelli un press del bene
questo sito praticamente ti fa delle
domande ti da due possibilità una
positiva e una negativa vi faccio un
esempio potrei avere i biglietti del
concerto della tua band preferita ma per
farlo devi tagliarti i capelli a zero
adesso io devo decidere se farlo o meno
se fa se lo voglio fare devo premere il
bottone se invece non voglio farlo devo
applicare ai un notch allora la mia band
preferita
credo di aver trovato il mio scopo nella
vita non posso usare la mia bella chioma
ragazzi quindi mi dispiace però no però
vabbè il grazie per avermelo chiesto
vuoi vivere a lungo quanto vuoi ma devi
iniziare dall'inizio dell'universo
trojan ascom col big bang fantastico
della serie che che io vengo al mondo
poi ci sono miliardi di gradi che mi
ricoprono in corpo magari anche no però
grazie la tua stanza è sempre pulita ed
organizzata ma vengo perché non lo è già
ma ci saranno sempre tre ragni nella tua
stanza e non potrei mai prenderli a
ucciderli certo perché mai non dovrei
farlo [ __ ] volete prenotare
preferisco la come prima nasce
all'inizio dell'universo che avere tra
ragni nella stanza quindi no grazie
potrai fare sesso sia sì donna che
perfetta asta domanda con qualsiasi
donna tu voglia ma non potrai avere un
orgasmo
[Musica]
ma chi cazzo se frega ma vaffan sarai
bella e tosta chioma ma che cazzo premi
in varie della viking ma piacerai sola
ragazza blu dei ragazzi belli io non ho
bisogno perché io io la mia spazzola che
mi rende figo avrei soldi illimitati ma
sarei sposato con la persona che ho
direi di più da persona che io odio di
più
porca [ __ ] e guarda parla chiaro
questa foto incredibile come sono
contento di sto matrimonio 5 milioni di
dollari ma non potrei tagliarti i il
mono sopracciglio ve lo giuro che ha la
soluzione è semplicissimo per non far
sembrare mano sopracciglio mono
sopracciglio rende un tatuatore bravo e
mi faccio da attuare in testa un'aquila
proprio così che sembra proprio che sia
spiccando c'è ragazzi è tanta roba qui
basta proprio un tatuatore bravo abbiamo
già reso quindi direi di sì zio la
voglia potrei giocare ai videogames per
il resto della tua vita senza fare pause
neanche per mangiare i braidesi tra
l'universo dei pokémon e sarà il maestro
di tutti i pokémon leggendari ma ogni
giorno sarai obbligato a uccidere un
pikachu
ancora piango per quel cazzo di film
figurati se lo faccio come come la gente
apro il 52 per cento ha premuto di sì
dài pikachu ma se le stronzi io non mi
sentirei obbligato a farlo io odio
quelle piccole merde ma sei scemo veli
mangerei ma va che cazzo preferirei
mangiare in essere umano che un pikachu
cei che i rolling scriverà un nuovo
capitolo di harry potter ma uno dei
protagonisti potrebbe morire ma sti
cazzi se n è villa ma venne vi il
poverino perché ma nessuno potrà mai
giocarlo con te va bene ci faccio il
gameplay va già bene potrei avere per
sempre 15 anni guarda già ce l'ho già ce
l'ho già
sono ventuno metano 15 uguale cadevo
spodestare il mio inglese scolastico
della terza media ma non avrai mai una
mente matura quindi già sono così
così si sta sempre facendo le cose
infantili e sono di cattivo umore perché
la scuola è zoppo se la scuola diventa
una toppa
diamogli una gamba nuova la scuola
praticamente c'è scritto che continuerai
a fare cose infantili e sarai sempre
negativo perché la scuola è una merda so
io cioè non è che c'è bisogno di
scegliere sono già così ma ho questa
ragazzi a stranissima potrei uccidere
justin bieber ma dovrei uccidere anche
il tuo cantante preferito è se il mio
cantante preferito fosse justin bieber
purtroppo il mio cantante preferito è
già morto quindi completamente senso
potrei vivere con la donna che vorrai
quanto a lungo vorrai ma potrei
indossare solo quello che lei dice devo
prima vedere i gusti di selena gomez
questo devo capire se l'enac e gusti
c'hai nel vestirti abbiamo o cristo
santo dovrei vestirmi come un medico
chirurgo tutti i giorni però spiegarsi
ne vale la pena rega avrei fisico che
hai sempre desiderato ma avrei la faccia
di nicolas cage è bellissimo chi è
chiusa ma anche al tocco di classe reca
mi sono dimenticato scusate eccolo qua
per adesso adesso sì adesso si re che
questo ragazzo è l'uomo del domani c'è
non è non c'è non c'è niente altro da
spiegare la devo mettere su instagram
voglio vedere i commenti vi prego
fotomontaggio
c'è qualcuno che ha scritto fatto
montano perché sicuramente c'è uno che
si è tatuato l'aquila in facciamo così
ed è ovvio è un miscuglio tra gigi
d'alessio non eccezionale che cosa
dovrebbe esserci di gigi insta foto il
fisico comunque si ragazzi perché c'è
dio mio no no no no no io sarei un
supereroe chiedere i fantasmi ma non
puoi vedere se non potranno saprei mai
se i fantasmi sono veri o se sono
persone vere della serie che vai al
supermercato mentre fai la spesa ti
trovi hitler alla cassa che comprai le
kartoffeln potrei fare sesso con
chiunque ma non sarai mai sposato
ok la smetto la smetto lasme potrai
sposare qualsiasi persona ma non potrai
mai divorziare mi dice che non posso
scopa avrai tanti bambini che potrebbe
essere buono o cattivo ha quindi si può
fare bunga bunga non è così male potrei
avere una riserva infinita di cibo ma
sarai obeso e morirai a 41 anni anzi non
c'è proprio possibilità ci ho già
provato sarà il ciccione accenno questo
ciccione india tutti quanti ti amano e
ti daranno 1.500 dollari al giorno
perché è perché se ciccio notarne
ciccione diavoli il 1500 o la lega a
caso si arredi fette già chi cioè
poverino re difetti gli arciglioni
addiction sotto di ciccio nizzo sarai
sessualmente impotente è un razzista
incompetente ma sarei accettato in
qualsiasi lavoro che vorrai fare non è
possibile perché se io volessi fare
l'attore porno non potrei perché sono
impotente vedi è che cosa fai ci metti
il lombrico motion che si sono spesso no
no no no ma perché non sapevo è infatti
non lo capite regalato la domanda
neanch'io
e così confusa avere così confuso la
colpirsi da solo tipo un po come potrei
avere la visione a raggi ics però puoi
vedere soltanto attraverso i vestiti e
non è così male perché dovrebbe essere
una cosa brutta scusa può vedere solo
lamentando ce l'hai il 76 per cento ha
detto sì ma ci crede potrai avere
desideri limitati michie fantagenitori
vi voglio subito potrai usarli solo per
fare del bene agli altri e non a te
stesso amico mio perché non desideri di
avere una lamborghini che così ci faccio
un giretto anch'io potrei avere accesso
a internet tramite il tuo cervello
ok qua qua già mi fermo non va bene va
bene un lego né mi interessa ci
immaginateli tipo utilizzare vostro
cervello come modem
se laghi vuol dire che sei stupido
perché non c'è la connessione fantastico
non invecchierà mai tipo jennifer
aniston questo l'ha fatto jennifer
aniston ma devi essere devi avere otto
anni per sempre mentalmente fisicamente
capottamenti metti davanti al televisore
tutto il giorno a te magni gelato
nessuno ti dice incazzo ma ha voglia ma
come no ma sei scemo potrei viaggiare
nel tempo sia nel passato sia nel futuro
ma sarei bloccato nella tua destinazione
all'arrivo sarà il nudo c'è praticamente
viaggio nel futuro così e poi compagno
coming callari ha terminato a perché
terminator
si materializzava con la minchia per
aria accordo ragazzi concluso che
l'episodio è stato etico cioè io do
annuncia posso fare quando vedo spiegare
bellissimo la adoro
spero che vito vi sia piaciuto è no no
so che cazzo dirvi perché ogni volta che
ciò che sta roba la mia vita migliora
ricorda il sacco di cose tipo che posso
mangiare senza ingrassare oppure che ho
15 anni e niente ragazzi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto cosa sergio se vi
è piaciuta sotto un commento è un mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e
coniglio tra tale iscrizione sentirsi
discreti amici vi davano prossimo vivo e
da ragazzi